spider-man and venom have long been the
best of arch enemies but that
complicated relationship hasn't quite
made it onto the big screen the comics
feature a true love-hate relationship
with highs lows and occasional team ups
to stop alien serial killers this is the
history of venom's relationship with
spider-man explained
the venom symbiote was first introduced
in 1984 as part of the line-wide marvel
comics crossover or some might call it
the glorified mattel commercial known as
secret wars the storyline sees numerous
heroes and villains from the marvel
universe kidnapped into space by a
godlike alien entity called the beyonder
who deposits him on a planet he dubs
battle world and demands they fight one
another in the eighth issue spider-man
needing a new costume is directed toward
an alien machine that can build him one
of course he picks the wrong machine and
is introduced to a small black ball of
unknown substance and origins which
quickly covers his body and takes the
form of a costume giving spider-man a
new look for the first time in the
character's history and presumably
giving mattel another reason to make new
spider-man toys
technically spider-man's black suit
pre-dates secret wars by more than 6
months spider-man mysteriously vanishes
from earth at the end of amazing
spider-man number 251 in april 1984 but
returns at the start of the very next
issue wearing the black costume with the
entirety of secret wars having occurred
between the two issues for the rest of
the year the events of secret wars
unfold retroactively in the pages of the
crossover book while spider-man wearing
the black suit continued to do his usual
stuff in his own comic he occasionally
considered how weird it was that his new
suit responded to his every thought but
he didn't have time to worry about it of
course he might have made time if he
knew what the readers knew that the suit
had started enveloping peter while he
slept dragging him around new york to
fight crime as spider-man without his
knowledge eventually after realizing the
suit had powers he didn't even know
about and after it had displayed
increasing reluctance to leave his body
spider-man finally took it to be
examined by reed richards of the
fantastic four who discovered the
costume's true nature
even for spider-man it's not every day a
super scientist tells you that the
costume you've been wearing is not only
a sentient alien but a sentient alien
that is trying to permanently bond with
you spider-man's repulsed reaction is
perfectly understandable from a human
point of view for the symbiote however
it was rejection and rejection led to
bitterness and hatred spider-man managed
to free himself from the symbiotes with
the help of the fantastic four who used
its weaknesses against sound and fire to
trap it in a containment unit for future
study eventually it escaped and managed
to trick spider-man into putting it back
on by disguising itself as his more
traditional blue and red costume it then
attempted to forcibly bond with him an
effort that peter was only able to
thwart by standing directly beside a set
of massive church bells exposing both
the symbiote and himself to their ear
shattering resonance the sound forced
the symbiote to relinquish its hold on
its unwilling host however despite
peter's rejection the symbiote saved his
life by dragging his body away from the
painfully loud noise foreshadowing the
troubled future of their relationship
even at this early stage there was love
mixed in with the hate
it would be three years before the
symbiote was seen again but when it came
back it came back quite literally with a
vengeance the final page of amazing
spider-man 299 published in april 1988
introduced the character now popularly
known as venom though he didn't have
knives for teeth or the long slavering
tongue quite yet
after being separated from spider-man
and the church the symbiote had found a
new host eddie brock a former journalist
whose life and career had been ruined in
his mind by spider-man preparing to
commit suicide the catholic brock went
to a church to pray for forgiveness
instead he found the symbiotes which
bonded to him not just physically but
emotionally through their mutual hatred
of spider-man naming themselves venom
brock and the symbiote instantly became
the webslinger's deadliest foe not only
did they not set off peter's early
warning spider sense but they knew his
true identity and were able to threaten
his loved ones while spider-man was
never able to defeat venom in direct
combat he survived the late 80s and
early 90s largely due to trickery in
their first meeting in amazing
spider-man 300 peter uses his knowledge
of how the symbiote works to defeat
venom while in amazing spider-man number
317 he pretends to take the symbiote
back revealing that the alien still
secretly wants to be with peter not
brock and the symbiote's attempt to
break its bond with brock knocks them
both unconscious
venom's next two major appearances set
up a major shift in his relationship
with spider-man which would see them
reluctantly team up in the face of a
greater danger amazing spider-man 333
features the apparent death of the venom
symbiote at the cancerous hands of the
villain's styx de-powered eddie brock is
imprisoned for his crimes and placed in
a cell with a serial killer named cletus
cassidy the symbiote however isn't dead
and it soon seeks eddie out and breaks
him free they continue to menace
spider-man this time fighting him on a
deserted island peter tricks venom for a
third time by faking his own death
escaping the island while brock and the
symbiote relax on the beach content in
the knowledge that their quest for
revenge is complete venom might have
lived out the rest of his days on that
island in peace if not for the spawn the
symbiote had left behind in eddie's cell
this second symbiote would bond with
cassidy transforming him into the
murderous villain known as carnage for
all venom's hatred of spider-man he's
always had a code of honor that usually
prevents him from killing the innocent
or allowing innocent deaths to occur but
carnage's bloodlust was indiscriminate
and when spider-man asked for venom's
help in stopping the killing spree venom
agreed it was the first time they would
team up to take down venom's crimson
offspring but certainly not the last
after dealing with carnage together
spider-man and venom eventually worked
out a truce that story involved both
peter's long-lost parents recently
returned and soon to be revealed as
imposters and eddie brock's ex-wife ann
wayne amazing spider-man number 375 was
billed as the final confrontation a
spider-man battled venom in an abandoned
theme park determined to stop him for
good and who had helped spider-man
locate her former husband arrived on the
scene to try and help but ended up
nearly being crushed by a falling ferris
wheel venom and spider-man were forced
to join forces to save her and afterward
anne helped venom realize that
spider-man regularly saves innocent
lives this revelation finally led to a
truce between the two with venom
swinging away to san francisco and into
his own limited series venom lethal
protector it was actually spider-man who
ended up breaking the truce in that
series when he went hunting for the
escaped venom but by the end the two
were working together again with venom
having completed his transformation into
a hero or at least an anti-hero
venom spent a solid decade from the
mid-90s to the mid-2000s hanging around
the marvel universe as a popular
anti-hero starring in numerous limited
series and finally getting his first
ongoing title in 2003. over this period
he had more adventures with anne wayne
who spent some time as she venom and
attempted to train and then when that
went south fight to the death a new
symbiote and host entity called toxin
among other adventures it was eventually
revealed that the venom symbiote was the
only thing keeping the cancer inside
eddie from killing him eddie meanwhile
also started to question whether being
bonded to the symbiote was influencing
him towards violence a theory seemingly
confirmed by his eventual slide back
into villainy and specifically a hatred
for spider-man the truce between the two
officially ended when anne committed
suicide and venom believed spider-man
was the cause in 2004 the symbiote went
full villain once again though eddie
brock did not having experienced the
religious reawakening after watching the
passion of the christ brock finally gave
up being venom selling the symbiotes at
a super villain auction the symbiote
first possessed the son of the mob boss
who bought him before finding a more
suitable host in matt gargan aka the
scorpion and remained an antagonist of
spider-man and various other marvel
heroes for the remainder of the 2000s
from 2011 to 2017 venom's host was a
very different spider-man character
flash thompson former spider-man admirer
and peter parker bully who lost his legs
while serving in the military when the
government decided to put the venom
symbiote to use it gave it to flash
allowing him to walk again and
transforming him into heroic agent venom
the symbiote wasn't bonded to flash at
first he was only allowed to use it for
48 hours at a time and the relationship
was an openly antagonistic one with the
symbiote taking any opportunity to seize
control and perform monstrous acts of
violence most of agent venom's story
doesn't directly involve spider-man but
their paths crossed an unusual fashion
in the pages of superior spider-man the
premise of this title involved a mind
swap between peter parker and his
longtime nemesis otto octavius aka dr
octopus who continued to fight crime as
spider-man while in his rival's body as
spider-man octavius forcibly extracted
the symbiote from flash and became host
to it himself calling himself the
superior venom in a fascinating reversal
however the symbiote sent something
wrong with its old plane while it
briefly tasted freedom by taking full
control of spider-man's body it was
expelled by a remnant of peter's mind
and returned willingly to flash
things didn't get any less weird for
ancient venom after dealing with the
superior spider-man in fact he ended up
going to space and joining the guardian
to the galaxy one of his adventures
while on the team finally gave an origin
story and even a home planet to the
symbiotes this story introduced klyntar
home of the symbiote hive originally a
species of conquerors the klintar had
repented of their ancient evil ways
seeking instead to become a force for
good they formed the agents of the
cosmos an organization of symbiotes
bound to worthy hosts who were dedicated
to fostering peace and justice
throughout the universe some symbiotes
however have been corrupted by their
hosts and the venom symbiote was one of
these upon its arrival back home the
klintar were able to cleanse it a
process that included a near-total
memory wipe of its previous hosts as a
result when agent venom returned to
earth and once again encountered
spider-man it had no memory of him the
symbiote even apologized to spider-man
and expressed the desire to one day earn
his forgiveness
if the klyntar memory wipe set the stage
for a reconciliation between venom and
spider-man the events of 2018 and 2019
brought their relationship full circle
by that point the venom symbiote had
been separated from flash thompson and
after a brief fling with an ex-soldier
named lee price it became bonded to
eddie brock once again and they were
once more the star of a venom ongoing
series it is happening again when
carnage bonded with legendary spider-man
nemesis norman osborne to become the red
goblin spider-man and venom as usual
teamed up to oppose him in order to
defeat red goblin brock willingly gave
up the symbiote to spider-man who donned
it again in amazing spider-man 800.
after the red goblin's defeat the
symbiote was transferred peacefully back
to brock it was a sequence of events
that demonstrated how far the two
characters had come and as if to
reinforce it during the 2019 event
absolute carnage the symbiote itself
convinced brock to join forces with
spider-man yet again a story that ended
with eddie brock who had sworn to kill
spider-man on numerous occasions
actually giving his old enemy a hug
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book characters are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]